Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is packed
to the brim with characters from all
across the Galaxy but one space variant
character was sorely missing why didn't
we get this cameo in the film spoilers
ahead a Trilogy can only end once and as
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 shows the
third movie can be a gold mine of cameos
and familiar faces with a series that's
feature as many characters as James
Gunn's Marvel Cinematic Universe face
Opera is no surprise that the Cameo list
gets pretty crowded in the conclusion
from Howard the Duck ends the car to the
brief return of Aisha there's a lot of
familiar faces in the movie even yondu
makes a brief appearance as a vision
that acts as kraglan's Arrow control
tutoring of course there is no time to
dwell on every single character the
Guardians have come across over the
years the film features by far the
biggest cast in The Guardians of the
Galaxy Series so far and has to juggle
the introduction of several new
characters with the conclusions of
several major character arcs all that
said it's frankly admirable that volume
3 manages to include as many known
entities as it does despite the
abundance of both familiar figures and
famous faces under various Aesthetics
there are two major players who we know
are still alive yet don't make a
physical appearance one of them is the
collector Who Sold nowhere to the
Guardians at some point before the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
and therefore has a perfect excuse to
stay out of Dodge on the other hand the
other person is a particularly glaring
Omission from the movie's extensive list
of cameos despite his close connection
to the Guardians in general and Rocket
in particular Thor odinson is nowhere to
be found there are several good reasons
for Thor to make a quick cameo in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. he used
to travel with the Guardians and while
he seems to have unwittingly annoyed
most of them to the point of Barely
getting a nod when he finally made his
exit let's be honest that's every
guardian's relationship with over half
of their team most of the time he's also
reasonably tight with the movie's
clearest main character and current
Guardians team leader rocket who took a
liking to the Asgardian after the
Thunder God treated him with respect you
seem like a noble leader will you join
me on my quest to live let me just ask
the captain
what's more Thor is currently in the
gardening business himself zooming
around with foster daughter loved to
fight evil in Far Away locations because
of all this a Thor Cameo wouldn't have
been just welcome it would have been
natural he could have popped up as a
brief background character or even
confusedly run into the new Guardian
Steam and a jokey Stinger that would
have explained why he wasn't helping out
in the movie proper he could have
auditioned for Rocket's team and been
turned down the possibilities were
endless yet the only time we see the God
of Thunder is a quick pick during the
end credits hey maybe the Guardians
really do dislike the guy and all parent
is the most likely reason for Thor's
Omission is probably the simple fact
that James Gunn never wanted to use Thor
in the movie and was grateful that taika
ytt closed the book on the connection in
Thor love and thunder if that's true and
he was never on board with the Thor
guardian's mashup it's likely that Gunn
was happy to keep the Asgardian off
screen in the conclusion of his trilogy
still it could have been nice to see the
big guy saying his farewells to the
classic lineup of the mcu's Premier
ragtech space team
foreign